[Applause]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
was sentenced to 150 days in jail for
faking a hate crime against himself in
downtown Chicago now that happened back
in 2019 now smilette claimed that he was
attacked on a freezing January Night by
two quote white supremacists wearing
Maga hats that shouted this is Trump
country and specifically targeted him
because of his race and his sexual
orientation of course we now know that
all of that was false Smollett actually
hired two of his associates to Stage the
attack and they are now telling their
story or their side of the story for the
first time in the new Fox Nation special
anatomy of a hoax take a look at this
so we got him got here 10 minutes to
spare and we had to plan our Escape
Route to survey the land his building is
actually right here right above the
stairs that we're going to attack him at
we made sure we got there at 2 A.M sharp
on the dot on the dot we had no phones
because he did not want us to bring any
phones he said so we don't lose them I
don't know if that's really the reason
that's him is that him that's that Nick
Nick oh he's moving fast come on let's
get him get that scare them as we
cross the street we say hey to get his
attention
hey Nick hey he turned around looked at
us and that's when we started yelling uh
the famous slurs he wanted us to yell
hey aren't you that Empire
fat Nick
it's magical country I mean he said what
did you say to me and then that's when I
threw the first punch at him and then I
threw him to the ground and while after
I threw him to the ground I he had no
bruise I wanted it to look more real so
then I threw him to the ground after I
threw him to the ground I used my
knuckle and gave him a noogie so I went
like this
why did I do that to give him a scar to
give him a mark to make it look real
like he really did get his ass beat all
right joining us now for their first
live TV interview are those two brothers
Ola and Bola ashun Cairo and
there Tony attorney Gloria Rodriguez
great to see you uh wow you ever think
it would become this big uh no
not in a million years no sir okay so
this thing begins to get into the public
Consciousness and people are rightly I
mean if that had really happened I'd be
angry I think most people deplore racism
uh most people people deplore uh people
that are anti-gay they should mind their
own damn business my view and so all of
a sudden this is viral and believed what
are you guys thinking
um before I allow my brother to answer
that question I just first want to
apologize to everyone in the audience
the country and anyone who might have
been affected by this directly
when we were asked to partake in this we
really didn't foresee the ramifications
of what something like this could do to
the country you're sorry you're
participated in it yeah yeah we didn't
we allowed our ambition to Cloud our
judgments we getting paid
um it wasn't about the money yeah it was
what was it about for you then
um the opportunity opportunity to well
we were actors so we are active we are
actors and Jesse right I'm acting as a
talk show host
do you want to do a hoax tonight and I'm
hoping one day maybe I'll get there
so Jesse was in a position where he
could help us because in the acting
world is who you know now what now so us
helping him out would have helped us out
yeah well you're their attorney you take
on this case and it explodes
and you did a great job by the way
congratulations thank you
um right
what was your initial Instinct because
you have clients that might be legal
Jeopardy here the whole world is
watching it gets tough in those moments
you know what
I had been doing these kinds of Crisis
situations for 10 years by the time I
had met the brothers so my immediate
thought wasn't oh my God this is a
national Spotlight case my immediate
thought was oh my God I have two
innocent guys here that are being
accused of doing this horrific hate
crime and so my natural instinct really
was to first unlike a lot of the
journalists that were out there
reporting this my my instinct was to
first get a handle on the facts and that
same night that I met them I went by
myself had to cancel my plans with my
wife and say I'm I got to go down to the
scene of the crime right and I looked
around and I just remember thinking it
is dark it is laid out and there's
nobody out here it's super safe it's
this is ridiculous how this would happen
and this particular night it was
freezing no no criminal would even want
to work that night right that the night
exactly the cold I you know let's take
the night off I'll get back to work
tomorrow night stealing and robbing
especially in Chicago all right so you
go through this and everyone our
audience was laughing because some of
it's really funny maybe really good
actors uh that's part of it but there is
a sad part of it here because there is
this impulse among people that they want
to believe the worst in human beings
that that people are racist and that
Trump supporters are are sexist and
racist and homophobic and xenophobic
islamophobic transphobic I mean as a
conservative I'm called these names all
the time none none of those allegations
are true I'm a Christian I believe in
God I I think he created every man woman
and child on this Earth so that's where
you know people are saying wow you're
demonizing a whole group of people have
you gotten to know people now that are
conservative and and maybe realize that
wow that could impact their lives
he hasn't you you're trying to let your
brother cover
not only have we gotten to know people
that were like that our parents are
pretty conservative although they are
Democrats but in their thinking they are
conservative and in turn we are
conservatives in a way we have
conservative views we have yeah we have
conservative views more conservative
views than uh liberal views anyway so
well hard are Republican my whole life
proud of it
um
you know some of the local papers when I
had ran for a little a local election
they were I had been running as a
republican for over a year and they were
still printing that I was a Democrat
because I'm a Latina and I must be I
must be okay I want to support your
campaign so come on
I'll tell you the best thing thank you
for coming I think people need to go to
Fox Nation watch this it's really
interesting and the best thing that you
both said is you apologize and you know
what I saw sincerity thank you for
apologize
uh thank you for being there she did a
great job today hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else